Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is Angela Lomang. I'm glad that you've
tuned in and you are going to be blessed
today. Yeah, you are. I'm always blessed
whenever I'm here hosting Q&A. I always
learn something new that will enrich my
walk with Jesus and I know it will
enrich your walk with him, too. Well,
thank you for your prayers and financial
support of this worldwide ministry. And
I have a Bible text I want to share with
you before we go on. And this Bible text
speaks to finding strength if you're
going through a hard time. And this is
one of my favorite Bible texts. It's
from Philippians 4:13. And it says, "I
can do not just some, but all things
through Christ who strengthens me."
Right. And Psalm
46:1, God is our refuge and strength, a
very present help in trouble. So if
you're in trouble, who is your strength?
God is your strength. Amen. Wow. Well,
we're going to go straight into our
wonderful guests. Not well, they're not
guests, are they? They are regular. You
see them regularly on 3ABN. So let's
start with Pastor James Rafidy. Welcome.
Good to be here, Angela. Angie, thank
you so much for those Bible promises.
They're powerful. We need those. We need
to go to the word of God. He's our
present help in all of our troubles.
Good to be here on the panel. Looking
forward to the questions we have today.
All right, we do have our sons of
thunder today, James and John. Hey,
Pastor John, welcome. Yes, hun. Good to
be here. That's right. The sons of
thunder are here today and thank you for
your questions. We're going to thunder
them from the word of God. All right.
Well, Pastor James, would we just open
with prayer for us, please?
Absolutely. Father in heaven, just want
to thank you for this time. We want to
give it to you. We want to give you each
and every viewer. Ask that you'll the
Holy Spirit will be with their hearts
that you will lead them to answers that
can encourage them and lift them up to
heaven to heavenly places in Christ
Jesus. We give you this time. We give
this program in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Now, if you have questions and you'd
like to send in your question, you can
email us at
bibleqa3abn.tv or you can text us at
6182283975 or if you have Instagram, you
can go to Instagram and go to
3ABN official. So, those are the ways
you can send your questions in. Okay,
speaking of questions, let's go to our
first question. Pastor
James, can you
explain Isaiah
45:7? This is from Jeremiah.
So Isaiah 45:7 is a really insignificant
verse. Thank you Jeremiah for sharing
this. It says, "I form the light and
create darkness. I make peace and create
evil. I the Lord do all these things.
Now the context of Isaiah 45 is
revealing God's judgments on Israel and
they were fulfilled through
Nebuchadnezzar. But it is it is also
revealing God's peace that is now being
fulfilled through Cyrus and Mid Persia.
In other words, God bought judgments on
Israel first and then he overturned
those judgments some 70 years later and
brought peace and allowed Israel to be
released from captivity in Babylon and
go back to their land and reestablish
themselves. Now the word here for create
is select. Right? Sometimes when we look
at these Hebrew words in their original
language, it helps us to understand the
meaning better. So when you look up the
word create, God here is is uh being
pictured as selecting something rather
than forming something out of nothing
like we understand creation to be. And
the word evil is bad and it can be
natural or moral. In other words, the
Hebrew word for evil can designate moral
evil or misfortune according to Proverbs
13:17. or could actually uh designate
harm according to Jeremiah 7 and:e 6. So
in Isaiah 45:7 the context suggests the
meaning is misfortune or disaster. The
NIV says it this way. I form light and
create darkness. I bring prosperity and
I create disaster. I the Lord do all
these things. Again, that's Isaiah 45:7
from the NIV. So the opposite of evil in
this sense is peace, prosperity, uh
personal safety. And the issue here is
not moral integrity versus immoral
behavior, but well-being versus
misfortune. In other words, the evil
misfortune here refers to the bitter
Israelite experience of exile. And then
we have the amazing promise of peace.
This refers to their restoration through
the work of Cyrus. So the evil and
misfortune that is being talked about
here that God created was the exile, the
destruction of Jerusalem due due to
their apostasy and the unfaithfulness
their unfaithfulness to God. So so in
spite of Israel's departure from God,
God overrules this disaster and he
brings them restoration through Cyrus.
So the context of the entire chapter
supports this understanding. In fact,
when we go back to pre Babylonian
captivity, we we look at the history,
for example, of David. David when he
sinned and was unfaithful to God, for
example, in numbering the people in 1st
Samuel 24 and:e 13, he was given a
choice between three consequences,
right? He was given the choice of se
seven years of famine for his sin or
falling into the hands of his enemies
for three months or falling into God's
hands. And guess what? He chose the
latter. He said, "It would be better to
fall into the hands of the Lord than
into the hands of my enemies." So the
history of David shows that it's better
to fall into God's hands and trust his
judgments and his mercy than to fall
into the hands of our enemies. And so in
Isaiah 45:7, God is reminding his people
that he oversees the consequences of
their evil in order to show mercy and
bring restoration and peace when the
time is right. And I hope uh Jeremiah, I
hope this uh has been helpful in
answering your question. Beautiful
answer. Yeah, I would rather fall in the
hands of of a loving, merciful God.
You're right. That's right. then into a
human's hand because the Lord is
merciful and Lord just was working on
Israel and Israel just kept falling back
and he's merciful. Thank you. All right,
honey. Here's your question. Can you
which is honey is my John. Can you
please explain numbers 15 verse
32-36? It seems like God is cruel to the
Israelites because they complain so
much. Okay, let's go to Numbers. I'm
going to turn there. Numbers 15. Yes.
Verse 32-36.
Now, what I want to read, I'm going to
go actually to my digital version here.
Numbers
15. Verse
32-36. Okay, let's look at that. And in
the
context what Israel and this by the way
is
um is the journey in the wilderness. The
Israelites were invited
to leave Egypt. The word invitation is
probably a small word. They were rescued
from the bondage of Egypt where they had
been for 400 years. 430 if you count
Joseph uh being in Egypt before they
arrived. And the Lord gave them no
conditions except the partaking of the
lamb, uh the the putting of the blood
over the
doorposts, and uh those whose house were
covered by the blood of the lamb and had
eaten the Passover lamb were prepared to
depart uh Egypt. But now with no
conditions outside of that, then the
Lord now carries them into the
wilderness to begin to give them
conditions. And the amazing thing about
that is, you know, the Lord loves us as
we are, but he never leaves us the way
he finds us. So he brought them out of
Egypt. It took them was an instant
event, but it took them 40 years to get
Egypt out of them. And so Numbers 15
describes the challenges that the
Israelites had in this constant desire
to want to rebel. They wanted to
continue to go back. And so when they
decided to violate the Sabbath, the Lord
made it very clear that there has to be
a message, a clearly sent message about
how God's how God feels about open
rebellion. And and so somebody says, "It
seems like God was being cruel." But God
is no more cruel to us as a parent who
loves his children is cruel to the
children because of their disobedience.
But I want to give you Ezekiel 18 21-2
because one of the one of the
indictments that the Israelites brought
against God was you're just not fair.
Look at Ezekiel 18
21-2. But if a wicked man turns from all
his sins which he has committed, keeps
all my statutes and does what is lawful
and right, he shall surely live. He
shall not die. That shows that God is
not looking to just kill someone because
of disobedience. None of the
transgressions which he has committed
shall be remembered against him. Because
of the righteousness which he has done,
he shall
live. Do I have any pleasure at all in
the wicked that the wicked should die,
says the Lord, and not that he should
turn from his ways and live? But when a
righteous man turns away from his
righteousness and commits iniquity and
does according to all the abominations
that the wicked man does, shall he live.
All the righteousness which he has done
shall not be remembered because of the
unfaithfulness of which he is guilty and
the sin which he has committed because
of them because of them he shall die.
Yet you say the way of the Lord is not
fear now oh house of Israel. Is it not
is it not my way which is fear and your
way which is which is not fair. So Lord
is in essence saying I'm not doing
anything unjust. I'm not being cruel to
you. But here's the reason why the Lord
metered out judgment as he began to
establish the way that he would deal
with his people throughout all time.
Ecclesiastes 8 and verse 11, the Bible
says, "Because the sentence against an
evil work is not executed speedily."
Therefore, the heart of the sons of men
are fully set in them to do evil. You
have an example in the Old Testament
where the Lord says, "They're going to
be disobedient. Take them out and stone
them." You also have an example in the
New Testament, Ananas and Safh, the
establishment of the New Testament
church. They dropped dead when they lied
to Peter. The Lord made it very clear at
the very outset that I will by no means
clear the guilty, but I am
long-suffering to those who are
obedient. So friends, God is not wicked.
He's not cruel. He's not evil. He's
setting an example that the wages of sin
really are death, but the gift of God is
eternal life. That's so true. like a
loving parent, as you said, that wants
to help their children and discipline
them. Sometimes discipline is hard, but
I've learned it's worth it in the long
run. Thank you. We've all learned that
hard. Yeah. Thank you, honey. Okay,
James, here's your five minute question.
What, this is an interesting one. What
does the Bible say about a narcissist?
This is from Steve in Oregon.
Thank you, Stephen. Or again, great
question. You know, the Bible gives us
the source of narcissism, but the word
narcissist is not actually in the Bible.
It comes from Greek mythology and its
attempt to explain the human condition
of selfishness. The brief story is that
in Greek mythology, narcissist was a
handsome youth who rejected the
desperate advances of eko. As a
punishment, he was doomed to fall in
love with his own reflection in a pool
of water. Unable to to um consummate his
love with echo narcissist with himself,
narcissists lay gazing and raptured in
the pool hour after hour and finally he
pined away uh changing into a flower
that bears his name, the narcissist. So
like narcissists, fallen humans are
selfabsorbed without God's intervention.
You understand that God has been
intervening or mediating in behalf of
selfish humanity from the very inception
of sin through the Holy Spirit and other
means. But uh we know that the epitome
of narcissism is described in the fall
of Lucifer, right? Lucifer was uh a
covering cherub. He was perfect in his
ways until iniquity was found in him. In
fact, we read about his experience in
Isaiah 14. Let's just look at those
verses. Isaiah Isaiah 14 beginning with
verse 12. It says, "How art thou fallen
from heaven, oh Lucifer, son of the
morning. How art thou cut down to the
ground which should weaken the nations?
For thou has said in thine heart, I will
ascend into heaven. I will exalt my
throne above the stars of God. I will
sit on the mount of the congregation,
the size of the north. I will ascend up
above the heights I of the clouds. I
will be like the most high." And again
in Ezekiel chapter 28, Lucifer is
described as this perfect covering
cherub who was perfect in his beauty in
the garden of uh God. Every precious
stone was this covering. Verses
12-15. And it goes on to say here that
you were the anointed sheriff that
covers. You were set so by God. You were
in the holy mountain of God. You walked
up and down in the midst of the stones
of fire, perfect in your ways until
iniquity was found in you. So our human
condition is the result of we could say
the Lucifer virus. We've all been
infected by it due to the fall. In
Genesis chapter 3, we read, "Now the
serpent, this is a symbol representation
of Lucifer, was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the Lord God
had made. And he said unto the woman, Ya
hath God said, Ye shall not eat of every
tree of the garden." And the woman said
unto the serpent, "We may eat of the
fruit of the trees of the garden, but of
the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of the garden, God has said you
not you shall not eat it, neither shall
you touch it, lest you die." And the
serpent said to the woman, "You will not
surely die. For God knows that in the
day that you eat thereof, you your eyes
will be open, and you will be as gods,
knowing good and evil." This is the
Lucifer virus, and we bit into it. And
it caused us to get our focus off God
and to get our focus now on ourselves.
That is why there's two facts of human
enlightenment that are so appropriate to
every human heart. Fact number one,
there is a God. Fact number two, you are
not him. So while the Bible does use the
ph doesn't use the phrase narcissist,
the idea of selfishness or being
self-absorbed or self-possession is uh
to the to the exclusion I should say of
neglect of others is the basis of the
human story in God's word at least on
the level of our fallen state. We
weren't created that way by God and we
will be recreated by God's grace to be
uh completely removed from all of the
self absorption and selfishness. And we
see that in the context of the cross of
Jesus Christ which reveals to us the
selflessness of God's character and
causes us to behold it so that we're
changed back into the image of God in
which we were created. We could
summarize narcissism. Paul does a good
job summarizing narcissism which infects
all of us. All of us. Sometimes you
point to others and say, "Oh, my son, my
relative, my neighbor, my co-workers is
a narcissist." But all of us are
infected with this virus. And only by
the grace of God can we overcome it?
What then? Are we better than they? Paul
says in Romans 3: uh 9. No. And no wise.
We have proved both Jews and Gentiles.
We're all under sin. As it is written,
there's none righteous, know not one.
There's none that understands. There's
none that seeks after God. All are gone
out of the way. They're alltogether
become unprofitable. There's none good.
No, not one. So, our only hope for
overcoming this infection, this Lucifer
virus infection of self-absorption and
selfishness is to accept the grace of
God, behold Jesus Christ, and allow him
to transform our characters. Wow. Well
said.
That was good. You know, Satan is the
head narcissist, isn't he?
And I like that story about looking the
reflection in the in the water. That was
a good story. That was a good story.
Thank you for that, James. Okay, honey.
Here's your five minute question. Okay.
What is the meaning of Revelation
10-11? I don't understand why the
righteous that overcomes will not be
hurt by the second death. If they are
righteous, why will they need to die the
second time? This is from Mar Marvanne
from South Carolina. Okay, thank you for
the question. By the way, they don't
need to die a second time. Uh the Lord
is in essence saying in Revelation 2:10,
they won't die a second time. Let's go
ahead and read the verse and we'll break
it down even more specifically. Do not
fear. Revelation 2 verse 10. Do not fear
any of those things which you are about
to suffer. Indeed, the devil is about to
throw some of you into prison that you
may be tested, and you will have
tribulation 10 days. Be faithful unto
death, and I will give you the crown of
life. Verse 11, he who has an ear, let
him hear what the spirit says to the
churches. He who overcomes shall not be
hurt by the second death. So the
righteous don't need to die a second
time. The righteous won't die a second
time because the wages of sin is death.
But the gift of God is eternal life
through Christ Jesus our Lord. And the
righteous will not be affected by the
wages of sin because Jesus paid those
wages to redeem them from the curse of
sin which is the wages of sin is death.
Now this concept of second death is
something that the Bible makes very
clear. If you look at John 5 28 and 29,
the Bible talks about the second death.
I'm going to use a couple of examples.
Start in John 5 28 and
29. Jesus says, "Do not marvel at this.
For the hour is coming in which all who
are in the graves will hear his voice
and come forth. Those who have done good
to the resurrection of life. those who
have done evil to the resurrection of
condemnation or damnation as the King
James version says. Now watch this. They
have all they have all died the first
death because all who are in the graves.
They have all been affected by the first
death because all have sinned and fallen
short of the glory of God. Romans 3:23
and Romans 5:12. Because of Adam, death
has passed to all of us. So we are all
going to die. Everybody has a grave
somewhere. We don't know when we're
going to die.
But we that are in Jesus Christ will not
die a second time because we come forth
to the resurrection of life. And the
resurrection of life is when we begin to
live eternally. We put on immortality. 1
Corinthians chapter 13 and uh 1
Thessalonians chapter 4. We put on
immortality. We put on incorruption. We
won't die a second time. And that's why
we go on now to Revelation 20 and verse
6. We speak about the resurrections.
Blessed and holy is he who has part in
the first resurrection. Over such the
second death has no power. But they
shall be priests of God and of Christ
and shall reign with him a thousand
years.
Notice those who come forth in the first
resurrection are in the resurrection of
life. Therefore, they'll never die
again. And because now 1 Corinthians 15
26, the last enemy that will be
destroyed is death. Revelation says
clearly in Revelation 20, there will be
no more death, no more suffering, no
more sorrow, no more crying, no more
pain, neither shall there be any more
death. Why? The former things are passed
away. So those who are uh have received
immortality and those who are
experiencing eternal life and those who
are incorruptible cannot die a second
time. And that is what the Lord is in
essence saying. So this second death is
only for those who do not die in the
Lord. Blessed are the dead who die in
the Lord, right? That they may rest from
their labors and their works do follow
them. Revelation
14:13. But there's something else about
those who die in the Lord. Precious in
the sight of the Lord is the death of
his saints. Why is the death of a saint
precious? Because they die in the Lord.
What does that mean? If you die in the
Lord, you're dying in the promise of
coming forth from the grave. You're
dying in the promise that when you come
out, you'll come out in the first
resurrection. Yes. Now, here's the clue
or here's the word of encouragement.
Revelation 21:8, another reason why
there'll be no second death is found in
Revelation 21:8. Now, all those who
enter into the new Jerusalem will keep
the commandments. But what about those
who do not enter? The Bible says in
Revelation 21:8, "But the cowardly,
unbelieving, abominable, murderers,
sexually immoral, sorcerers, idoltors,
and all liars shall have their part in
the lake, which burns with fire and
brimstone, which is the second death."
So those who are in Christ are not the
liars and abominable. The Bible made it
very clear in Revelation
22:1. He that is unjust, let him be
unjust still. He that is righteous, let
him be righteous still. He that is holy,
let him be holy still. He that is
filthy, let him be filthy still. We are
all locked into two categories,
righteous and holy, or filthy and
unrighteous or unjust. And whatever
category you're in is your category for
eternity. And the righteous are in the
holy and just category. No second death.
Wow. But well said. But some will be
alive when Jesus returns. Right. That's
right. Yeah. There will be some that
will be alive and they'll never see the
first death. Okay.
Amen. Thank you for that. Well, well
answered well. And it's all answered
from the word of God. Amen. Now, if you
have just tuned in and you say, "Oh, how
could I get my Bible question in?" Well,
you can go and you can email us. It's at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
TV or you can text us at
618-228-3975. If you're an Instagrammer,
you can also go to Instagram. Go to
3ABN official. So, send your questions
in. We'd love to hear from you. All
right, here we go. Uh, Pastor
James, what is the meaning of Hebrews
8:13?
Does it mean the first five books of the
law are obsolete or just the priestly
atonement? This is from Lana in
Oklahoma.
Thank you, Lana. That's a great
question. Hebrews 8:13 is referring to
the new covenant in contrast with the
old covenant. At least that's the
context that we find in these verses.
We'll start with verse 6. It says Paul
is speaking here about the old covenant.
He says, "But now he has obtained a more
excellent ministry by which also he is
the mediator of a better covenant
covenant which was established on better
promises. For if the first covenant,
that is the old covenant, verse 7, have
been faultless, then should no place
have been sought for the second. For
finding fault with them, he saith,
Behold, the days come, says the Lord,
when I will make a new covenant with the
house of Israel and with the house of
Judah, not according to the covenant
that I made with their fathers in the
day, verse 9, when I took them by the
hand to lead them out of the land of
Egypt, because they continued not in my
covenant. And I regarded them not, says
the Lord. That was the fault, by the
way. He found fault with them because
they didn't continue in his covenant.
They made promises that they would do
all the Lord has said, but they didn't
do all the Lord has said. And so they
made faulty promises to God. Promises
they couldn't keep. And by the way, we
are not promisekeepers. God is the great
promisekeeper. It doesn't matter how
many men you put in a football stadium.
None of us can keep promises to God. But
God always keeps his promises to us. So
verse 10 says, "For this is the covenant
that I will make with the house of
Israel after those days, sayeth the
Lord, I will put my laws in their mind
and write them in their hearts. I will
be to them a God. They shall beat to me
a people and I will be merciful to their
unrighteousness. Um I excuse me verse 11
says and they shall not teach every man
his neighbor and every man his brother
say know the Lord for all shall know me
from the least to the greatest. Verse 12
and I will be merciful to their
unrighteousness and their sins and
iniquities I will remember no more. And
then verse 13 and here's your verse. In
that he saith a new covenant heath made
the first old. Now that which decays and
waxes old is ready to vanish away. So
what has been made old? What has been
done away with? The old covenant. Right?
So reading this last verse, verse 13, in
its context, it's the old covenant was
done away with. What is the old
covenant? It's relating to God and to
his plan of salvation with a belief
system that your work that your words,
that your promises are brought to the
table and they're meritorious. You're
going to be able to do what you promised
God you can do. It's trusting partly in
God's promises and partly in man's
ability. We see this highlighted in the
book of Galatians 4:es 21-26. Paul
actually summarizes the way that we
relate to God in our Christian
experience in the New Testament as
either old covenant or new covenant. He
says here, "Tell me ye that desire to be
under the law." Verse 21 of Galatians 4,
"Do you not hear the law? For it is
written that Abraham had two sons, the
one by a bond man made, and the other by
a free woman. Verse 23, but he who was
of the bond woman was born after the
flesh, but of the free woman by promise.
He's talking about Ishmael with Hagar.
Abraham getting together with Hagar and
depending on the flesh, and Isaac, where
Abraham and Sarah had a child, a promise
that they couldn't produce because both
of them were too old to have children
according to Romans 4. which things are
an allegory, he says in verse 24, for
these are the two covenants, the one
from Sinai, which genders to bondage,
and the other which is which is Hagar,
and the other uh um excuse me, verse 25,
for this is Hagar and Mount Si in Si in
Arabia, that answers to Jerusalem, which
now is and is in bondage with her
children, but Jerusalem, which is above
is free, which is the mother of us all.
So, running out of time here, but just
to to put a capstone on this, Hebrews
8:13 means that the old covenant way of
relating to God and salvation is passed.
It's obsolete. For we all now embrace
the new everlasting covenant, and that
is trusting wholly to God and to his
promises rather in trusting partly to
God and partly to ourselves. I hope this
is helpful.
Thank you. Thank you so much, James.
Well, well answered. Always from the
word of God. Okay.
John, here's your question. According to
the Bible, there are three heavens.
Okay. In which heaven was Satan's heart
lifted up? This is from someone in
Canada. Okay. Yes. Thank you so much for
that question. And you add you answer
some of the question when you add since
God dwells in the third heaven, was his
heart lifted up in the first or second
heaven? Well, you know, that would have
been amazing because the first and
second heaven as this controversy is
going on was out of the context of the
controversy. Let me go ahead and read
about the controversy. Revelation 12
7-9. The Bible says, "And war broke out
in heaven. Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon as and
his angels fought, but they did not
prevail. Nor was a place found for them
in heaven any longer." So the great
dragon was cast out. Revelation 12:9,
that serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world. He
was cast to the earth and his angels
were cast out with him. Now you have to
ask yourself the question, let's look at
the heavens and we break them down. The
first heaven according to Genesis 1
verse 7 and 8 is the firmament which is
right above the earth. We might call
that the atmosphere, the different
layers, the atmosphere, the hemisphere,
the troposphere, the ionosphere,
different levels also called the
firmament. Genesis 1 verse 7 and 8. Thus
God made the firmament and divided the
water which was under the firmament from
the waters which were above the
firmament. And it was so. And God called
the firmament heaven. So the evening and
the morning were the second day. So
before the flood there was a canopy that
surrounded the earth and there was water
above it and water below it and that was
called heaven. That was the first
heaven. What about the second heaven?
David describes it in re in Psalm 19
verse1. The heavens declare the glory of
God, and the firmament shows his
handiwork. Day unto day, utter speech,
and night unto night reveals knowledge.
There is no speech, nor language where
their voice is not heard. Now, to find
out this one, go visit Pastor James in
Yusede. Look up at the skies at night,
and you'll see the heavens declaring the
glory of God. Oh, here too. We could do
that here, too. Also, at night,
sometimes we go outside, turn all the
lights off, and the heavens create a
light show that no human can ever
duplicate. That's right. It just starts
twinkling and the longer you look the
brighter it gets. That is the second
heaven. The planets, the stars, the
solar system, the heavens declare the
glory of God. Those planets remain in
orbit continuously from generation to
generation declaring that God is a God
of uncanning order. But the third
heaven, Paul describes this and he talks
about those who were in vision. Let's
start with 2 Corinthians 12 and verse
two.
Paul talks about a person in vision. He
says,"I know a man in Christ who 14
years ago, whether in the body I do not
know or whether out of the body I do not
know, God knows such a one was caught up
to the third heaven." Now, this was not
ascending to heaven and just going to
heaven. But Paul is saying whether he
was awake or whether he was sleep, he
was in vision. Now, there's an example
of this when Peter was sleeping waiting
for his meal in Acts chapter 10. He was
sleeping and he had a dream. And the
Bible says, "A sheep was let down from
heaven." A vision. He was in vision.
Then you have in Revelation chapter 4
and verse one, John talks about being in
vision. He says, "After these things, I
looked and behold a door was standing
open in heaven. And the first voice
which I heard was like a trumpet
speaking to me, saying, "Come up here,
and I will show you things which must
take place after this." Now, John did
not physically go to heaven and come
back after the vision, but John was
caught up in vision. So, this is clear.
And then lastly, the place where the
rebellion took place is talked about in
Isaiah
14:12. How art thou fallen from heaven,
oh Lucifer, son of the morning. How art
thou cut down to the ground, you who
weakened the nations? For you have said
in your heart, I will ascend into
heaven. I will exalt my throne above the
stars of God. Those are the angels. I
will also sit on the mount of the
congregation on the farthest sides of
the north. And we know how that story
end. He said, "No, no, no. You'll be
cast to the ground and his angels were
cast out with him." And that's why Jesus
caps this off by saying in Luke 10:18.
He said to them, "I saw Satan fall like
lightning from heaven." And that's where
God abodeed. So today, friends, we can
see clearly that there is no rebellion
in heaven. The third heaven is safe. And
one day by God's grace, we will all be
there. Amen. And sin shall not rise up
again, will it? That's right. No, not in
heaven. That's right. Not in heaven. Be
a place of peace and love and joy
forever more. Aren't you looking forward
to that? Yes, I know I am. Oh, thank you
so much. All right, Pastor James, this
is an interesting question, and I'm sure
some of you have been through this. It
says here, "I've been married and
divorced three times before the age of
40." Wow. "Since being
rebaptized, am I now destined to be
alone until my
death? To not be an adulteress? I don't
know who sent it. It was sent as a
text."
Well, the Bible does say that God hates
divorce. That's in Malachi chapter 2 and
verse 16. And the reason why is because
divorce separates what God has brought
together. And what God brings together,
no man is to separate. It leaves two
people who were once united alone. And
God did not want us to be alone. In
fact, in Genesis 21:8, the Lord God
said, "It is not good from the man that
he should be alone. I will make him an
help meat for him." So this verse
applies to mankind. It includes the
woman because that was the help meat God
made for the man. And so and he and she
was made of the rib, right? So divorce
not only makes us alone again but it
makes it harder for us to have a
marriage that will endure into the
future because now we have baggage.
Number two, not impossible but harder.
In other words, just want to emphasize
this. The failure of one time weakens
our hope for happiness in the future as
well as weakening our endurance because
we gave up once, it'll be easier for us
to give up again. Marriage is not easy.
Marriage is a challenge for human beings
to be unselfish in their love and
affection for another person. We just
talked about narcissism and the
infection of selfishness in the human
DNA. Number three, divorce leaves us
less secure about ourselves and more
vulnerable to the criticisms of those
around us. So we be we become more
insecure and therefore an insecure
person has a harder time finding a a new
relationship. Number four, it can also
develop a habit of giving up on
relationships and on ourselves. Just
completely giving up when times get
tough. And of course, number five, it
hurts our children. Divorce hurts not
only ourselves, but it can have lasting
effects upon children, not fully
understood by society today. And so,
this is why God hates divorce. These are
five reasons why God hates divorce. He
hates divorce because of the impact it
has on us, on others, and on society at
large. Now, being alone for the rest of
our lives is not really God's number one
option for most people. Though, it can
definitely work for some, especially for
those who the Lord God is calling to,
you know, live a life of singleness.
There were some people in the Bible who
lived lives of singleness, for sure. And
Paul even talks about that some people
may be called to that, uh, for sure. But
God wants us to have intimacy. And of
course, he can make up for the lack of
intimacy uh among human relationships.
God can be our husband for sure. Uh but
here's what the Bible says about your
future. Just to give you some hope, in 2
Corinthians 5:17, it says, "Therefore,
if any man be in Christ, he is a new
creature. All old things are passed
away." Old things are passed away, and
behold, all things are become new. So
you mentioned that this was something
that you experienced before being
rebaptized and and becoming a new
creature in Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ
says you begin a new experience in him.
He says you are unconddemned for your
past in Christ. You leave behind your
old life of sin and you begin to live a
new life of righteousness. And if God
has a plan for a man in this new life,
he will make that known. But begin with
God as your husband. God is your
provider. God is your protector. God is
your comforter. God is your best friend.
Here are some Bible promises that I want
to share with you. Just look at these
and let God speak deep into your heart
and your mind and your spirit. It's
Isaiah 54:es 4 to8. Here's what it says.
Do not fear for you will not be ashamed
neither be disgraced for you will be put
you for you will not be put to shame for
you will forget the shame of your youth.
You will not remember the reproach of
your widhood widowhood anymore. For your
maker is your husbandment. The Lord of
hosts is his name. And your redeemer,
the holy one of Israel, he has called
the God of the whole earth. For the Lord
has called you like a woman forsaken and
grieved in the spirit. Like a youthful
wife, when you were refused, says the
Lord your God, for a mere moment I have
forsaken you, but with great mercies I
will gather you. With a little wrath,
I've hid my face for a moment, but with
everlasting kindness, I will have mercy
on you, says the Lord, your redeemer.
That's Isaiah
54:4-8. So, you're not doomed to live a
life of loneliness and singleness. For
you have a heavenly husband, and you
have a new beginning in Christ. Your
past record has been made clean and your
future begins brand new.
Amen. He throws your sins into the
depths of the sea. Micah 7, is it 7:19?
and he remembers them no more. So don't
go fishing. All right. Don't bring it
up. Thank you for that. That was well
said. Okay. All right. Pastor John,
here's your question. In John
14 16-1 17, Jesus said, "He will leave
the spirit of truth with the disciples
that the world cannot accept because it
neither sees him nor knows
him." Was this a special spirit that
dwelled within the disciples?
It is it difficult? Is it different from
the spirit that dwells with us today?
This is from Nikki in Florida. Actually,
it's not. It's not at all. You know,
there's one Lord, one faith, one spirit,
one God, one baptism. There's only one
spirit. Yes. The spirit of God works in
amazing ways. And I'll read the passage
there that you referred to. John 14:16.
And I will pray the father and he will
give you another helper or another
comforter as the King James version says
that he may abide with you forever. The
spirit of truth whom the world cannot
receive because it neither sees him nor
knows him but you know him for he dwells
with you and will be in you. That power
that residing in indwelling Holy Spirit.
You know the Bible says what is the hope
of glory? Christ in you. Well, how could
Christ be in you? Through the work of
the Holy Spirit. This is a promise made
to all believers. If anyone is in
Christ, we are in Christ and Christ is
in us. How? By the Holy Spirit's
presence. But the work of the Holy
Spirit is done in three ways. And you've
heard me talk about this before. Uh
first way he does and John 16 talks
about this. John 16:8, I'll read the
passage and then talk about how he
works. And when he has come, he will
convict the world of sin and of
righteousness and of judgment. The first
way the Holy Spirit works, he works on
us. bring us to the point of conviction.
That's the most important part. He can't
do the other two unless you respond to
the first one. When you respond to the
first one, he now takes you to the next
level. I'll read the passage then
describe what it is. Galatians 5 22 and
23. But the fruit of the spirit is love,
joy, peace, longsuffering, kindness,
goodness, faithfulness, gentleness,
self-control. Against such there is no
law. Meaning the law that bound you in
sin is broken. So what's the second way
he works? First on us, secondly in us.
In other words, people need to see that
we are in fact connected to Christ. When
they see those fruit, love, joy, peace,
longsuffering, when they see a patient
Christian, they say, "There's something
different about him. There's something
different about her." We've had those
experiences in just walking in society,
walking into the hospitals, people say,
"What's different about you? Are you
Christians?" outside of Marie
Calendarers in California and then the
hospital in San Francisco. Is your
husband a Christian? When those fruits
are visible, they know that there's
something different inside of your life.
But the final way he works in 1
Corinthians 12:4 and 7, there are
diversities of gifts, but the same
spirit. There are differences of
ministries, but the same Lord. There are
diversities of activities, but it's the
same God who works all in all. But the
manifestation of the spirit is given to
each one for the profit or benefit of
all. The last way he works is first on
us, then in us, then finally through us.
He'll never work on I mean in you and
through you unless you respond to him
working on you. So, so no, this is not a
different spirit because the Bible says
in Joel chapter 2 verse 28, "And it
shall come to pass in the last days that
I will pour out my spirit on all flesh.
Your sons and your daughters shall
prophesy. Your old men shall dream
dreams. And your young men shall see
visions. I'm I don't know if I'm in
dreams or vision. I'm somewhere in the
middle, right, James? We're in the
middle of dreams and visions. But
finally, John 16:13. However, when he,
the Spirit of truth, has come, he will
guide you into all truth. For he will
not speak on his own authority, but
whatever he hears, he will speak, and he
will tell you things to come. So, it's
not a different spirit. No, the spirit
that worked on the disciples is working
on us. And I pray that that spirit is
also working in your life. And matter of
fact, thank you. Matter of fact, we're
doing a study about the Holy Spirit. So,
there's a sweet spirit and he's working
on your heart and on mine. Remember
that. Okay. Thank you, honey. All right,
James. Here is your last question.
Matthew 24:20 says, "Pray that your
flight may not be in the winter or on
the Sabbath." Which Sabbath is this
referring to, the Jewish Sabbath or the
Christian Sabbath? This is from Lynn.
Thank you, Lynn. Great question. You
know, when the Bible talks about the
Sabbath, there's no distinction made.
The Bible Sabbath of the Christian is
the same Bible Sabbath of the Jew. It is
the seventh day Sabbath. sanctified,
blessed, set apart for rest from the
creation of the world according to
Genesis chapter 2, uh, verses 1-3. So,
there's only one Sabbath in the Bible.
For there is no other day except the
seventh day Sabbath that was ever
commanded by God or kept holy by Jesus
Christ but this one Sabbath day.
Christians who are followers of Christ
keep the Sabbath Christ kept, which is
the only one God gave and the only one
his true followers keep. Christians who
do not keep the seventh day Sabbath do
not do so because God has given them
another Sabbath. For the Bible, God's
infallible world does not command
another day. So the warning from Christ
in Matthew 24 to pray that our flight
not be in the winter nor on the Sabbath
day is referring to the seventh day
Sabbath, the Bible Sabbath for
Christians and for Jews. It is the same
Sabbath. It is the one Sabbath. There is
no other Sabbath commanded in the Bible.
And this is one of the clearest New
Testament verses that actually confirms
Sabbathkeeping not only in the first
century but also just before the second
coming of Jesus Christ. In other words,
the Bible here is telling us that Jesus
knew that the early Christians of the
first century would be keeping the
Sabbath all the way down through the
destruction of Jerusalem. It also tells
us that Jesus knew that God's end time
people in the very uh days before his
second coming would also be keeping the
Sabbath. And there are thousands, if not
millions of Christians and
non-Christians today who are
rediscovering the Bible Sabbath, the
seventh day. You see, Matthew chapter 24
is a parallel prophecy. It points out
the signs that would lead both to the
destruction of Jerusalem in AD.70 and to
the end of the world. And so, here Jesus
is clearly indicating that God's early
church would be a Sabbathkeeping church.
But it's also indicating that God's end
time people prior to the second coming
of Christ would be a Sabbathkeeping
people. And that is the 7th day Sabbath
identified in Genesis chapter 2 and all
the way through scriptures Exodus 28-11.
And of course kept by Jesus Christ and
kept by his people all the way to the
end of time. In fact, this is affirmed
in the prophetic book of Revelation
chapters 12:17 and 14:12, which
specifically talks about those who keep
the commandments of God during the mark
of the beast crisis. So Lynn, just to
answer your question succinctly, there
is only one Sabbath in the Bible.
Christians keep that Sabbath. Jews keep
that Sabbath as they follow the word of
God and they follow the the direction of
Jesus Christ. And as we come into the
mark of the beast crisis, we are to
follow the lamb wherever he goes, which
includes keeping the commandments that
God has given us all through his word. I
hope that's helpful.
Answered very well. And it's always from
the word of God. There are no there is
not a a Jewish Sabbath, a Christian
Sabbath. There's only one. Amen. Well
said. Okay, Pastor Lomang, here's your
final question. On a previous Bible Q&A,
someone asked if our name was in the
book of life at the beginning of our
life. I only see our name being blotted
out, not added to the book of life. Is
our name written in there already? Okay,
very quickly for the quence, the our
names are not automatically added to the
book of life at birth. Right? We are
born in sin by Adam's fall. We are
fallen in nature. We cannot be added to
the book of life while we're in a fallen
situation. While we're in a fallen
nature, John 1:12 says, "But as many as
receive him, to them he gave the right
or the power to become children of God
to those who believe in his name." So
when, as Pastor James pointed out, 2
Corinthians 5:17, "If anyone is in
Christ, he is a new creation. Old things
have passed away." You've got to be in
Christ for your name to be added to the
book of life. That's why the Bible says
in 1 John 5:12, "He who has the Son has
life. But he who does not have the Son
does not have life." Now, what? Don't
miss it. If you have life, what book are
you in? The book of life. If you don't
have the Son, you're not in the book of
life. Yeah. Matthew uh 13:38, it made it
very clear that there are two
categories. When we say we're all
children of God, you know, honey, that's
not the truth. Because Jesus himself
said in the parable of the wheat and the
tears, Matthew 13:38, "The field is the
world, the good seed are the sons of the
kingdom, but the tears are the sons of
the wicked one." Those who are not
converted are still children of the
wicked one, but those who are acceptant
of Christ, who have received him and
believe and live for him are the sons of
the kingdom. And that's why Revelation
makes it very clear. Revelation 13:8
when Pastor James talked about the
Christ is to come it says all those who
dwell on earth will worship him that's
worship the beast whose names have not
been written in the book of life their
names were never written there of the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world so you see clearly how does your
name get written there John 3:18 he who
believes in him is not condemned but he
who does not believe is condemned
already because he has not believed in
the name of the only begotten son of
God. So friends, here's the point.
You've got to believe in Jesus. There we
go now to the most beautiful passage in
the New Testament. For God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believes in him, here's
the key, should not perish. So
therefore, what book are they in? The
book of life, but have everlasting life.
So the privilege of anybody who has the
spirit working on your heart, friends,
if the Lord is speaking to you and
working on your heart and and bringing
you to the point of conviction, the
blessing is respond to that work so that
you can accept Jesus and your name is
added to the RSVP list. those who are
invited and those who are responding.
And one day we'll sit at the welcome
table at the marriage supper of the lamb
because our names are written in the
invitation book, the book of life. Wow.
Well said. Is my name written there in
the pages bright and fair? That's where
I want my name to be. Well, we're going
to take a short break and we're going to
come back with some closing thoughts.
We'll be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975. That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live. And then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word. Were you blessed today? Oh, I know
you're saying yes on the other side. I
was blessed. I hope your questions were
answered. And I know they were cuz they
were by the word of God. And we had the
two sons of thunder, James and
John. So anyway, we are we're just going
to go to a few closing thoughts by the
sons of thunder. We're going to start
with the first son of th son son of
thunder, James Rapidity. Pastor James
Rapidity, share with us. Thank you,
Angie. I just wanted to go back to that
question about the woman that was
married three times and and felt
destitute and designated to loneliness.
You know, there's a story in the Bible
in John chapter 4 of a woman who was
married five times and was living with a
man when Jesus introduced himself to her
and ex uh extended to her an invitation
to accept of the water of life. And
that's what Jesus does. He gives us an
invitation to accept of the water of
life, of the gift of salvation that
truly satisfies the deepest needs of our
heart. Sometimes we're looking for love
in all the wrong places. And when we
receive the love of God that truly
satisfies the deep longings of the
heart, we can be satisfied with him as
our husband. Now, if in that state of
experience that God decides, hey, you uh
I can give you another marriage on
earth. I can bring into your life
another person who can also meet some of
those needs. Praise the Lord. But if
not, we can leave our hearts with God.
He will take care of them until the new
heavens and the new earth. Wow. Well
said. There's always hope, isn't it?
Especially when you're in Jesus, he
gives you hope. So, don't give up. Okay,
Pastor John, let's hear your and your
final thoughts. Well, talking about
heaven, heaven is going to be a
beautiful experience. But in reality, we
only know what the Bible tells us about
heaven. No more death, no more sorrow,
no more crying, no more pain. All those
things are passed away. And we just have
that beautiful picture of the new
Jerusalem, but not of heaven. You know,
the Bible talks about aspects in Isaiah
about heaven and some of the Old
Testament prophets, but we really don't
know what heaven is going to be like in
its entirety. But I can tell you what
it's not going to be like. Revelation
21:27, "But there shall by no means
enter into it anything that defiles or
causes an abomination or a lie, but only
those who are written in the Lamb's book
of life." The question is, is your name
written there? Thank you. Thank you for
joining us. Thank you panelists. You've
been wonderful. And my closing thought
is from Psalm
119:1. Your word I have hidden in my
heart that I might not sin against you.
Until next time, have a blessed day in
Jesus name.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.